so we have some pretty big feel politics to
talk about today over the weekend. Some Saudi
oil facilities we're
attacked and the Trump administration is increasingly
looking at Iran as the culprit. And before
we get into sort of like the specific analysis
anytime in in the Trump era that we're doing
in analysis of geopolitics, there's sort of
like the normal analysis one would do based
on the last 200 years of American history.
And then you have to modify that analysis
to account for the fact that Donald Trump
is president of the United States. And analogy
that came to me over the weekend is sort of
like if you have an airline pilot that flies
a particular airplane right in Airbus three
30 and you say, what is the takeoff speed
of the Airbus three 30 and you have your like
in a vacuum answer, which might be 150 knots,
but then much like you have to account for
Donald Trump being president in geopolitics,
you then have to account for whether the runway
is dry or wet and what is the elevation of
the airport and other things.
And you might have to end up with an answer
where all in this particular case, the takeoff
speed for an Airbus three 30 is 160 knots
when accounting for these other factors. And
similarly with Donald Trump thrown into geo
politics, we have to account for Donald Trump
in making our evaluation. So a few different
things to go over. It's the event that took
place, the hypocrisy from Donald Trump and
also the growing subservience by Donald Trump
to the Saudis, which is something that we
should all be extremely worried about in particular
because of the connections. We already know
Trump and Jared Kushner and others around
him have to the Saudis. So first of all, why
the focus on Iran so far? What we know is
that a number of Saudi oil facilities were
attacked over the weekend. We have satellite
images that show 17 points of impact coming
from the north or the northwest, which could
be Iran, it could be Iraq.
Now in the immediate and the Iranian backed
who the militias are, who? T militias. I'm
never sure how to pronounce that from Yemen
claimed responsibility. And there are reasons
to be skeptical about this. Um, the direction
of the attacks is at least a potential reason
to be skeptical. The use of cruise missiles
and drones seem to exceed the known capabilities
of the Hutus and Donald Trump as usual, is
reacting to everything in the worst possible
way. A radic indirect and sort of showing
his cards that he is indeed subservient to
the Saudis. A hypocritical subservience is
maybe how I would it up. So first of all,
Donald Trump tweeting Saudi Arabia oil supply
was attacked. There is reason to believe that
we know the culprit are locked and loaded
depending on verification, but are waiting
to hear from the kingdom as to who they believe
was the cause of this attack.
And under what terms we would proceed. Look
at all of the extremely disturbing elements
just to this one tweet hinting at Iran, but
not saying we have reason to believe we know
who did it. Why not just come out and say
it locked and loaded. It's a threat of violence.
But again, it's predicated on Donald Trump
having reason to believe that he knows who
it is. But saying that once the Saudis tell
him who they believe did it, he's locked and
loaded and ready to go under whatever terms
the Saudi say are the ones that Donald Trump
should operate under. This is a level of subservience
to the Saudis. And then we get to the hypocrisy
because Donald Trump in 2014 tweeted, quote,
Saudi Arabia should fight their own wars,
which they won't, or pay us an absolute fortune
to protect them and their great wealth trillion
dollars. Of course Donald Trump was not president
at the time.
Barack Obama was president at the time. So
was that just bs and political bluster? Probably
the other possibility is Donald Trump actually
has made some kind of deal with the Saudis
for the u s to be their protector. And in
a way that deal has sort of been made in plain
sight for decades through American foreign
policy. Donald Trump may well see, and it
actually wouldn't be that crazy. He may see
the endless and infinitely growing, uh, arms
deals with Saudi Arabia as that sort of payment
to the United States for the protection of
the Saudis. You may recall that when Barack
Obama sort of semi bowed to the Saudis, when
they were greeting each other, the Wright
went crazy even though George W. Bush was
kissing the Saudis on the cheek and they seem
to find with it at the time. Now Donald Trump
is saying, when the Saudis tell me who they
think did it and when the Saudi's telling
me what the appropriate response would be,
we're going to go out and do it.
Really strong leader, right? Projecting strength
and independence and focusing on what's best
for the, Oh, wait, no, he's really not. Some
of the bigger geopolitical questions here.
Does Donald Trump want a war with someone
to help the arms industry? Is that sort of
what is at the core of what's going on here?
Does Donald Trump want a war with someone
so that he can finally be the tough guy that
he of course is not but desperately wants
to be? Does Donald Trump want a war with someone
because he believes it will help his reelection
after all, that would not be incorrect in
a sense. I'm trying to think of when the United
States voted out and incumbent president in
the middle of a war or significant engagement
and I'm having trouble thinking of that. Maybe
there are examples, uh, and or because this
is all obviously not just one thing, it could
be a combination.
Does Donald Trump won a war because it will
be a distraction from one of his many current
or up upcoming scandals. A combination is
usually sort of the right answer. With this
president, I got a lot of emails from the
audience over the last year saying, David,
at some point Trump is going to war. The question
is who will it be against and under what pretenses?
But the guy is going to find a war one way
or another. Either John Bolton is going to
help him, or if John Bolton is the impediment,
Bolton will go, which he since has and Trump
will find a war on his own. Maybe not a more
cynical than a reality actually suggests here.
And of course immediately the economic impact
is significant, relatively minor in the context
of the broader insanity, but oil prices spiking
about one sixth from 60 to $71. We don't even
get that much of our oil from Saudi Arabia.
The notion that we are dependent on the Saudis
for the oil itself is wrong. I mean they have
a big market share, but from my recollection,
we get around, uh, 11% of our total oil consumption
from foreign countries. And of that 11%, I
think it's 9% only is from Saudi Arabia. So
the actual numbers don't bear it out. But
of course a massive player in OPEC and in
controlling the oil market. So an economic
impact right away. I don't know where this
will go. We'll keep following it. I want to
hear from you about it. But this is of course
going to be a very, very crazy year leading
up to the November, 2020 election.